video game characters are too ugly this
a weird thing that keeps popping up in
news that I wanted to talk about today I
know I've addressed this in a Q&A very
briefly before but I'm going to dive a
little bit further into it today both
because I think there's a part of this
that people are not understanding and
because I have what I think is like
maybe my least popular opinion of all
time I don't know it's at the very least
a hot take so the first part of this is
that uh you may have seen it make the
round some of the memes have been
admittedly very funny I'm not going to
take that away from them where an image
of Mary Jane and Spider-Man 2 has been
revealed this is what she looks like uh
and I think that this is probably just
in this oneoff I think it's like a clip
from like a yearbook photo or something
like that um I don't imagine the
character actually looks like this like
functionally in gameplay which I think
is a thing that comes up a lot in these
conversations about female video game
characters getting too ugly it also
happened with aloy in Horizon zero Dawn
which is the last time that I addressed
this but also recently happened with the
protagonist of fable or at least to
where assuming is the protagonist of
fable you don't really know anything
about that game yet which sucks so
excited about it but uh this is
similarly definitely got a lot of heat
for being not hot enough which I find to
be like a little bit funny in the case
of fable because his characters have
always been goofy looking but for Mary
Jane specifically and some came out and
said that they are using the exact same
face model the face model has not
changed and again this is a still that's
supposed to look kind of like a yearbook
photo I mean I think a lot of video game
characters look kind of unsettling when
you have them POS in a photo mode kind
of pose but for the first part of this
let me just address this suggestion that
female video game characters are getting
uglier and and where I think a lot of
that is being misdirected so it's partly
true it is partly true that video game
characters in general uh especially I
think in Western markets just because
that's the style of game they're getting
more realistic could be perceived to be
being less attractive the reason for
this I don't think is what people think
I've seen people suggest that it's
because there are more female game
developers though I will note that there
are a lot of female game developers I
pretty regularly have meetings at my day
job in game development that are just
rooms full of women just entirely women
I do think there are a lot more women
involved in making games than a lot of
people realize and directly related to
this conversation I cannot speak for
everybody obviously and don't want to
like have that kind of stance but I
would like to share the sex mini games
in the original God of War games were
actually designed by women it's like
this part where you go into Aphrodite's
chamber and it's like got this like
flowing kind of like fabric over her bed
uh designed to look like a laia like a
female vagina by female game developers
uh I think a lot of people like
attribute all of that to men and every
time I see that they're like yeah back
when men were making video games girls
did all of that they did it back then
this isn't a new thing so that's one
attribution so the reality is just that
games are getting more realistic and
that there are several like really
beneficial parts to human characters
having more human faces so as video
games getting more realistic looking our
peap technology which is performance
capture which is where you know you see
someone with like a camera in front of
their face motion capture is when
they're moving their bodies performance
capture is able to pick up more nuances
of the human face and so hand in hand
with improved graphical Fidelity in
video games you are able to actually
capture more like micro movements in the
human face so your face scans need to be
more accurate and in general a little
bit more human thus more flawed humans
have a bunch of flaws on their faces
this is a very common part of Being
Human nobody's fully symmetrical nobody
looks cartoonish so as video games in
general are getting less cartoonish
again this is why I think it's specific
to the West I feel like there are still
a lot of Japanese games made with like
more anime art styles it is easier to
make somebody look perfect essentially
and thus less like a real human but you
have to have more accurate face scans
that can't just be about symmetry where
like maybe they would have created a
face that looks a lot more cartoonish
because then you are picking up the
facial expressions those micro
expressions in people's faces and you
are often taking a model and mapping it
onto the performance capture and
blending those two things which is an
awkward process in general especially if
your models are different to your actors
which is actually the case for Mary Jane
who I believe is voiced by Laura Bailey
so you're kind of mashing two people's
faces together as well to get the
movement right which is like a pretty
awkward process especially if they have
very structurally different faces or
very different ways of speaking that's
often why there's a very new trend this
is much much much more recent of trying
to cost models that uh have again
similar facial structures to your
performance artists and the reason that
there's such like a huge benefit to
doing this not just like because realism
sells it's not just that that's not
really the goal with this the goal with
getting more accurate facial capture and
performance capture is a lot more about
selling stories we know there are swats
of data not only from like actual
psychological studies but also from
things like Netflix and YouTube uh like
testing that say an expressive face in a
thumbnail guarantees more views on a
video this is like huge on Netflix
there's also statistics from data from
multiple streaming servfaces about
audience for attention rates being
higher if there are more human faces on
screen effectively the longer that you
go without somebody expressing in a TV
show especially now that we're having
these streaming Wars the more likely
they are to click off human faces are
very engaging to humans and so when
video game storytelling is progressing
at such a significant rate like I really
feel like it's it's getting better and
better and better and and this
technology is so helpful for that the
point is that the more Expressions on
the face the more engaged you are in the
story but also the more human the
characters feel the more you can
empathize with the characters that
you're looking at the the more you
believe their performances the better
the performances come across the better
the performances effectively are so it's
not just about having better graphics
and that's having uglier women because
they hate women or whatever but it's
more that you have more human looking
people who Express in a more human way
which is ultimately helpful to video
games as a medium top to bottom and
there are so many ways that having more
expressive characters who again have
more of these micro Expressions that
often come with faces that are not
perfect or cartoonish or overly polished
can actually benefit storytelling and
video Gam games which is like still such
a huge challenge I'm sure I'll make a
separate video at some point about the
notion that video game writing is bad
and while that is true in some cases
it's honestly largely just that it's so
hard to keep people engaged if they
don't have a face to look at they don't
care there are just so many challenges
to delivering a story in video games
that one very obvious solution is
increase the Fidelity and the realism of
emotions being visible on people's faces
to line up with the actors who are
making it clear in their voices that is
the reality of why this may be perceived
as being a thing that is happening I
don't fundamentally
disagree uh I just think it's being like
hugely over exaggerated and like
excessively scrutinized to a weird
extent but again you do you fill your
boots so the other facet of this that I
want to talk about that um I think is
probably a spicy take and I address it
because I've had people ask me before or
assume the opposite of me for whatever
reason and I do want to be clear this is
just how I feel I don't want to
misrepresent any women in game
development any female Gamers at all the
fact that I feel feel this way does not
mean that women at large feel this way I
do think that across the board in a lot
of Western media obviously not all of it
there are so many examples of this not
being the case there is like an odd
mascul ma
masculation
masculinization
masculine essentially what I'm trying to
say is I do feel like there has been an
increase in female characters and often
female protagonists I feel like this is
especially happen happening in like the
Disney era of film and TV presenting as
more masculine I mean if I talk about
some of my favorite video game
characters my favorite three female
video game characters are Jade from
Beyond Good and Evil who looks like this
I never felt like Jade was overly
sexualized um I feel like the reality of
this is that she has dressed how so many
women I know dress you got a singlet you
got a pair of pants you got a nice
jacket but it's not like covered head to
toe 24/7 I love Jade I like the way she
looks um I think that she is a realistic
woman to me in a bunch of ways though of
course women have various fashion senses
another favorite female video game
character is Joanna from perfect dark I
mean I was playing this game as a kid
and I loved Joanna and there are
sexualized versions of Joanna especially
in the reboot I think she was a little
more sexual but like originally she just
sort of looked like that she's got some
nice makeup on she's wearing a full
bodysuit she still looks feminine but
she wasn't like overly scantily clad and
then my number one female video game
character is aan dead or alive or from
Ninja giden as well and aane has like
plenty of outfit variety some of which I
think is very cute and feminine like
what a cute outfit that's just adorable
feminine cute some of it's sexy though
she is in the beach volleyball game and
I love these characters love the way
they dress and feel like they represent
uh me as a woman or at least the ideal
obviously you see me on YouTube I'm
always wearing baggie t-shirt it's very
rare that I wear anything that's
feminine but in my daily life I like to
dress in things that make me feel pretty
and feminine and I feel like there is
kind of an increase in female characters
especially female leaders fic from uh
book of Boba Fett stands out to me
really really strongly I think this is
um the actress is stunning she is a
beautiful woman but in order to like
sell the idea that she was badass which
is like another Trope that I think is
kind of played out with female
characters at this right it's like you
just have to be badass and what they
mean by that generally is just like hard
and masculine like usually the selling
point for badass strong female character
just means like sort of Acts a bit like
a man and even that I mean what is that
even mean like like a stereotypical man
very stoic and a little bit grumpy a
little bit and like attitude like
doesn't take from nobody and it's
like just super one note like I do think
there's place for those characters and I
do think there are place for women who
act like that and there are women who
act like that in the real world it's
just like this huge wave of that kind of
female character who also has to dress
in this particular way and it's it's a
really odd one to me because that it
feels like there's this strange
Narrative of if you want to be seen as a
leader if you want to be seen as strong
if you want to be seen as badass or boss
or whatever other adjective you want to
throw in there a lot of films TV shows
some video games I guess are really
painting it to me that you can't be
feminine that in order to be taken
seriously as a woman or to be this kind
of character you have to be like the
dudes who would be in this role and it
just seems so bad backwards to me again
my preference is a very boring one and
it is in favor of diversity I would
prefer to have multiple options to have
every swath of character Under the Sun
it makes our story so much more
interesting again so many of this like
badass woman Trope is just the same one
character type swapped out with like a
slightly different background and to me
it's like the opposite of what I want in
that uh I'm someone who's always
struggled with working in a male
dominated field and how feminine I am
perceived as being I'm very very very
well aware of a phenomenon where like
the more more feminine a woman who works
in the games industry dresses or
presents the more people tend to
question how much she actually likes
video games or what she's really doing
there and so when you have like these
same nerd things reinforcing that to me
like when I already get comments all the
time being like I really respect you as
a gaming YouTuber because you wear
t-shirts I think people will have oddly
more hostility if I wear something that
is more feminine if I wear a dress if I
wear a fril shirt whatever even if I
wear more makeup people can get really
hostile in the comments and be like why
have you done this woman stop being
womanly and that's the thing that sucks
it's like a weird pressure that sucks
and so to have so many nerdy spaces fill
their female protagonists with the same
kind of energy again I think it's like
very prevalent with Star Wars like
especially when you compare the way Star
Wars was to the way that Star Wars is
it's just you I feel like it's
reinforcing this thing that feels shitty
just feels kind of sucky it just feels
like a bummer now this isn't something
that I'm like losing sleep over it's not
a huge deal it's just an opinion on a
side of this that I haven't seen
expressed before I Am pro sexy character
personally I Am pro women dressing in a
more feminine Way I Am pro female
characters having diverse backgrounds
and emotions and feelings and approaches
and definitely Pro female characters
still being able to be leaders and cool
I mean 2B stands out to me as an example
2B from near autometer this is how she
dresses okay if you're not familiar this
is like one of my favorite games ever
made that's how she dresses she got a
little boob window she's got cute gers
and like giant heels I think she's still
really cool and very strong and very
important to that world and it doesn't
take away from itself and I feel like
that's something that I like like seeing
like I would like to see that while also
seeing the other versions across the
board in
conclusion video game characters need to
be more realistic and need to have
better face scans and performance
capture and as a result they can look
less cartoony and less pristine and less
perfect
and the other aside again think it's
probably a hot take maybe a really
unpopular opinion I would much prefer a
large swath of variety in characters and
am Pro women being feminine sexy sexual
and also being cool boss strong whatever
and also being weak just the whole lot
and I just don't see that opinion shared
super often um and also people tend to
assume that I think the opposite which
is totally not the case of course we do
still have plenty of sexy fem on video
game characters Street Fighter just came
out it's not like it doesn't exist in
the suggest and that it doesn't as silly
there are just like maybe certain swats
of franchises or or cultures where that
is happening like I do feel like that's
happening in Star Wars I don't know dude
I just as a girl who like I said I am
aware that um if I wear things that are
a little more girly on YouTube that
people really don't like that I just
don't love seeing nerd media reinforce
that that in order for female characters
to be cool powerful boss whatever they
can't also be like girly you know does
that make sense I don't know please
don't cancel me for this one